[Music]  Ryan Reynolds candidly addresses his  struggles with anxiety and his fractured  relationship with his late father James  the Deadpool star appears in a new  feature story for the journal on mr.  Porter comm where he opens up about his  turbulent childhood with a tough father  he revealed quote growing up in my house  it was never relaxing or easy and I know  that throughout my life I've dealt with  anxiety in different ways  despite their complicated relationship  Ryan paid tribute to his dad in 2014 by  naming his first child after him a girl  named James he explained quote my father  died soon after my daughter was born but  he got to see her which makes me happy  as for Ryan's wife Blake Lively he  credits her with helping him repair his  relationship with his dad before he died  simply explaining quote she has a gift  for foresight she really does just show  me how to be better in almost every way  as a father as a person everything  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]